hey there folks welcome to pro tips from
pros chefs
[Music]
i am andrew ray of binging with babish
decidedly not a pro chef but they gave
me some air time and i'm gonna use it to
talk to you about salt and pepper it
sounds pretty boring right
but it's not
there's actually all kinds of salt and
all kinds of pepper but i'm going to
show you the ones that you need the most
in your home kitchen
first up we have table salt this is the
salt that you're probably most familiar
with it's the one that's on your dinner
table it's the one that comes in the
cylindrical cardboard tube with a little
metal spout that always breaks off and
ruins your day see how the salt just is
cascading from my fingers while it's
very good for baking not so good for
cooking because first off as you can see
i can't pinch it you see how i have no
control over what's happening below my
fingernails i feel out of control right
now i'm not a man in control of my
situation my life or anything really uh
just get rid of all this spilled salt
bad luck okay
so just so you know guys know we love
keeping in the flubs and the stupid
stuff so feel free to you know keep all
the silliness in
now for cooking as you cook more and
more often you want to salt to taste
that's what most recipes say right salt
taste for that you want to go kosher
salt kosher salt is the choice for chefs
the world over because you can control
it you can pick it up feel how much
you're grabbing here this feels like
about three quarters of a teaspoon to
make but i guess and then you can
control how much is going
into your
food and you get used to that and you
can cook more fluidly you can cook by
salting to taste that's what most
recipes say right
yes
so the last salt that i want you to keep
in your pantry is flaky finishing salt
now these are big old honk and salt
crystals you see that these are not only
going to add a nice little bit of salty
bite to your dish it's also going to add
a whole lot of texture it also looks
really nice this looks delicious and
tastes delicious on brownies on cookies
on your salted caramel on your steak
when you when you finish plating up the
steak and slicing it hitting a little
bit of butter and flaky salt
your guests will never leave your home
you'll have to call a lawyer about about
swatters rights it
didn't come to me fast enough
there's a salt these are the salts that
i want you to go out and buy right now
i'll wait
all right so
all right all right so let's get the
salts out of the way
let's get all this bad luck out of the
way look at all this spilled salt i'm
gonna die tonight from this
the babish bench scraper for the
discerning bench scraper
like as a person a person who describes
benches a bench scraper this is the
bench scraper for the one
of them that's just
[Music]
so next up we're talking about pepper so
this is the theme going on here salt and
pepper all right so you got it
pre-ground versus fresh ground this is
what most of us have in our kitchens the
stuff in the shaker the stuff in the
little square tin that has the pour a
whole lot outside and sprinkle a little
bit side right
no good for you uh that must mean that
you're using freshly ground pepper which
i am a huge advocate for because it
tastes bigger it tastes brighter tastes
more floral you can control the grind
size
that's about it but all those things are
worth the cost of admission alone and to
prove it to you i'm going to bring my
producer abby glackin right out right on
in here does it pronounce glacking or
blacken
okay all right cool
now i'm gonna mix these up close your
eyes please thank you keep them closed
and we have never met before right who
are you
all right
we have met before that was the joke um
so i'm going to mix these up and i'm
going to ask you to smell them
which is not a pleasant thing it's never
fun to smell pepper directly so i
apologize in advance but you're going to
tell me which one smells better big
whiff
okay smell anything okay that's peppere
all right now what about pepper bee
big whip
oh there's something there there's
something there see all right you want
something there you want nothing in
there and you want freshly ground pepper
thank you abby great to see you
well folks i hope i managed to teach you
something halfway interesting about a
very uninteresting subject until next
time my name is andrew ray go check out
my channel on youtube it's called binge
with babish and go to
drewberrymoreshow.com for more tips
tricks and drew
you